foreign
welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee first of all
some housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in Hawley Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the council offices
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have their image captured does
anyone intend to film the meeting
no
restriction on the use of mobile phones
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls while the
meeting is in progress
apologies for absence Alison if we any
apologies at all no
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest members no
so we moved to item three
application for a new premises license
at the stone Bay kiosk broadstairs I
call upon Mr katengi the council's
senior litigation lawyer to explain to
the parties the procedure that we will
be taking during the hearing
thank you
good afternoon
I would like to confirm that the
decision of this board are made in
accordance with the licensing act 2003
and based on the information presented
in in this agenda together with any
verbal submissions made today decisions
of the board are not politically based
this board must act impartially and
offer a fair and unbiased hearing of
today's application this subcommittee
will give Fair consideration to
everything it hears and reads today we
are here to consider an application for
a new premises at the stone Bay kiosk
broadstairs in accordance with the
licensing act 2003 we will hear the
parties in the following order the last
as an officer to present the report the
applicant's questions for the licensing
officer members of the licensing board
questions for the licensing officer the
applicant to address the committee the
last certain questions for the applicant
or the Representatives members of the
committee questions for the applicants
once all of the relevant representations
have been made with the exception of the
board members and the Democratic
Services officer and the legal officer
you will be asked to leave the chamber
so that the licensing board can
deliberate and come to a decision on
your application this should take around
30 minutes after which you will be
invited back into the chamber for the
announcements of the decision thank you
would the technical support team manager
please present the report
afternoon everyone
we received an application for a new
premises license at the stone Bay kiosk
in broadstairs
that's attached to the agenda along with
the the plan
the applicant has to advertise on their
premises and in a local paper and this
was done and we received a number of
representations which was 20 and again
they are attached to the report
the representations were sent to the
applicant and he asked us to send an
email to all the people who put in the
representations explaining what he was
actually applying for
so we sent that and we had after that a
number of the representations sort of
they basically all said they still
wanted to be considered
um so they're all attached we've
received no representations from the
police environmental health a licensing
officer or the fire service
the police agreed some conditions with
the applicant and those are also
attached at Annex five so
um over to you too
listen to the applicant and the
one other thing since I wrote this
report the Estates Department confirmed
with me that they've issued a license to
the applicant to be able to have tables
and chairs on the prom and on part of
the beach so that's all been agreed with
the Estates Department
okay uh members do you have any
questions for Alison
um when I was looking
looking through the objections
there was a common theme about previous
issues with noise can you tell me how
many complaints that you've received and
what action was taken
I've just checked that with the team
downstairs and we haven't received any
noise complaints
okay any other questions for technical
support manager okay thank you
okay now I'll turn to um Mr Antilla and
the applicant uh would you please
present the application
um so Mr Dylan was going to attend with
me today but comp for health reasons so
I've come on my own so give it a good
shot so we've applied for uh drinks
application license for down at Stone
Bay
and would you like you to tell you the
reasons why is that
we should do now here so
um we've sort of created a family hub
for the beach which has um lots of sort
of fitness and well-being and all with
the e-forces to try and keep it for the
community
there's over 300 Beach Huts down on
Stone Bay and um last year was our first
year we held a residence meeting with
local residents and the beach hut owners
to introduce ourselves and to say that
this is us this is our you know our
number and we're looking to bring a bit
of vibrancy to Stone Bay and appreciate
that it's it's been a small Kiosk for
many many years
and so we're looking to apply for a
drinks license which would not be the
core part of our business but would
accompany the sort of food and the
Ambiance of the area that we'll be
looking to provide and and given that
all of the other Bays have um drinks
licenses we'd just be following on salt
from the other the other Bays but it is
we're not looking to create a sort of
bar or a club environment in any way
shape or form it'd be one beer one rose
wine
so very limited
offering
that's it
oh just yeah
um yeah the beach is well known I mean
like most of our beaches in thanet um as
being popular with families uh how would
you cope with the situation where you
had a table
um people sat down having having lunch
had a couple a couple of beers and they
get a little bit louder as tends to
happen after a few drinks uh and that
there's profanities or you know some
sort of language that might not be
appropriate in public uh how would you
or your team be coping with that and
what measures are in place to do so
thanks well we would obviously have
staff training so we'd teach our staff
how to look out for people that are
intoxicated or if people have walked
along from another Bay they may have
been drinking on other bays and they
come along to ours so we'd certainly
look out for that we would police a
local area and we wouldn't be using any
glass at all or you'd be no glass at all
given out it'd all be plastic
and we would be very Vigilant to what
people are ordering and given that the
beer that we'd have would just be a
session beer we wouldn't be looking to
put any sort of strong lagers on
um so that would be how we would and
obviously with CCTV on as well we would
be um we'd have everything monitored
thank you
can I ask is the CCTV up and running no
not at the moment
um okay so we will be putting CCTV in
subject to uh an application today okay
thank you
uh yeah have you had any representations
from um Neighbors about noise to to date
and if so how have you dealt with them
um not as such we had last season
um we was playing some music from the
Hutt
um
wasn't loud music or Amplified music in
any way and um someone did mention that
the music was slightly more than
background music and we turned it down
on that occasion
um and we've always said to anybody
there that the doors always open come
and see us and uh you know we're here to
we're here to offer a service for
everyone on the beach but nothing
because no no sort of formal complaints
were made to us in a you know in writing
or um we didn't feel we had any problems
last season
thank you
yeah can I ask with regard to the music
is the music sort of more sort of
background music uh it's not actually uh
music for nothing to hear no that's
right no there's nobody um there's
there's nobody there that's going to be
benefiting from you know halfway down
the beach getting loud music played and
we've got we've got Beach Huts right
next door to us
so roughly very cautious of the
surrounding area uh you know who's next
door Etc so um no it's background music
okay does the uh
does the technical support team manager
have any questions for the applicant
not so much a question but obviously one
of your conditions you've agreed with
the police is for CCTV isn't it so that
is the condition of the license that
will need to be there
um
they will get pulled up if that you know
it is a proper condition of the license
so that will be there yeah
sure
we actually had some anti-social
Behavior down there last night which um
a lot of the beach art owners and local
residents would know living there that
um in the summer months you get a lot of
kids down on the beach having fires
taking crates down Etc so unfortunately
the beach Huts next to us got broken
into so did the area behind us were they
threw our chairs around Etc so I think
CCTV would be a good thing anyway and we
believe that by us being down there and
being sensible adults that that may
deter
groups of children and kids and
teenagers from going down and and using
that area as a redundant part of the
beach which it currently is you know if
we was never open
thank you
yeah
um yeah one of the I mean you've alluded
to that there with the antisocial
behavior on the beach and kids going
down having fires and things which start
usually quite good-natured but they can
deteriorate and very often in the
morning you're going to find broken
glass and other problems down there
um have you participated in or been
involved in any of the beach cleaning
activities down there as a local
business and stakeholder there
so yes we have last year we we had two
Beach Queens
plus we um we actually kept the main
stairway clean and swept all the excess
sand off and stuff our staff currently
check the local area so every every
morning that they open they check the
area to make sure for example there's
you know no old crates that have been
burnt and carried Nails Etc
um and so yeah we keep our area clean
and tidy our Promenade is swept every
morning and we maintained the area and
make it you know as safe as we can
um I'd like to ask um would you both
like to introduce yourself before we ask
him
Mr and Mrs Martin Christine thank you
okay Mr and Mrs Moulton um uh is it Mrs
Moulton that's going to introduce the
yeah yeah okay would you like to State
your case of um of objection yeah
um can I just say we've both lived along
the Esplanade for 32 years during that
time I was actually a head teacher of
two of the local schools my husband ran
the unit for very disturbed youngsters
we believe that we know quite a lot
about difficult youngsters now having
lived there for over 30 years I have to
say the way the arrangement works at the
moment is really good except for times
when exams finish and that's when you do
get the noise and the disturbance just
described we haven't complained about
that because we work with young people I
I was head of three secondary schools
one in tar Hamlet's morning found it one
in deal so we're very familiar with the
way youngsters behave and how to control
that behavior
we are very disturbed we've done a risk
assessment on the six to nine o'clock or
ten o'clock slot in particular because
you see at six most of the families that
presently use that beach and use it in a
very positive way go how do I know that
because I sit upstairs in my house and
look out over the sea I can see Stone
Bay the steps going down to it I see it
in the morning as the dog walkers arrive
I see it at six ish when basically a lot
of the people do leave to feed their
children as indeed they should
I in particular am very concerned about
the risk to anybody working there
because you know as well as I do you
provide the licenses that lots of pubs
in broadstairs and they're actually 150
different outlets for food and for
drinks in broadstairs I checked it only
this morning
you know that there are many bounces now
in broadstairs because people with a
drink problem actually become a major
nuisance I think what is six to nine
o'clock or six to ten o'clock provision
is going to do is encourage people that
have been barred from the pubs and the
clubs locally in broadstairs to come to
our end of the beach why because it's so
very secluded and that's okay in the day
when you've got lots of families there
but at night it's not okay and what
we're doing is putting your staff at
risk including your cell phone see me
but also putting young people at risk
because if they know there's provision
there a bit of music some drinks and so
on they're going to be more attracted to
that area than they are now and for a
longer period of time
and that worries me very much because if
they get into trouble they've got 50
steps they've got to mount to get out of
trouble or they've got almost
um a three-quarters mile walk to get out
of trouble
and that just wouldn't happen people are
going to get attacked and I think you
need to listen to the fact that between
six and ten you'll starve for a
tremendous risk because how are they
going to get the police there how are
they going to get an ambulance there if
it's needed because right now the
toilets close at six as you very well
know so there are no such facilities
there's almost no way you can get hold
of the police and the ambulance I know
friends have talked about it and I've
discovered it
and
don't think so many young people at risk
you
drink I mean I've been teaching
secondary school kids for 40 years 20 of
those so I had teacher and unfortunately
youth is youth if there's a chance of
getting hold of drugs for instance in a
fairly secluded area of stone Bay that's
what they're going to do and there are
lots of places to hide and frankly any
staff that you have and yourself should
not approach people who are selling
drugs taking drugs
and basically I've had too much to drink
I'm absolutely certain of this I've been
there for 32 years I have never
complained about any noise we both
understand young people very well indeed
I used to run discos but I always had
help I used to get parents who were
policemen who were prison officers to
come and Patrol with me we searched bags
researched individuals before they came
into the Disco why because if we didn't
we would have ended up with a drugs
problem and a drink problem and that's
what you have to do and at the age of 14
we even stopped doing discos for them
because of the issues involved in London
I used by the way to have my Judo team
come and manage the school with me you
cannot allow young people access to a
place where they could be sold drugs
sold outcome Hall bring their own
alcohol where there's a bit of light
there's a bit of noise between 6 and 10
is what I'm particularly concerned about
as indeed are all the residents I'm
chair of the neighborhood association
and we've all objected pretty much it's
not just the stone Bay chalets and there
has been vandalism there'll be a lot
more you've just described it and thanks
for being honest about that but if you
attract young people to that area you
are creating a major social issue that
does not exist at the present point in
time
and I'm just going to concentrate on
that and the issue about the toilets is
just so important to so many of those
Stone Bay Hut holders because where are
kids gonna go to toiletware and it was
going to go to toilet we know that they
already do it sometimes you know those
times I've described
already but that's a short period of
time and I don't see there's a need for
this facility because people who live
locally leave around six so what on
Earth are you thinking of for putting
your staff at risk between six and ten
o'clock at night you would there'd be no
doubt about that and I'd be the first
not just to say I told you so I'll be on
the phone to you and not only that I
shall be very happy to support any
member of Staff who sues you for putting
them at risk which they would be at risk
there is no doubt whatsoever in my mind
about that
foreign
do you think that the problem with the
anti-social behavior on the beach is
with people bringing their own alcohol
um
I'm not sure what what price is the the
the the beach kiosk will be charging but
I imagine that Supermarket alcohol is is
going to be the Preferred Choice and
that's what generally we see on thanet
beaches at the moment so from that point
of view do you how how could you explain
why you you think that um the
availability of alcohol at the beach
kiosk would exacerbate that problem I I
heard the obviously the separate to the
the point on um
perceived risk to to staff but in terms
of the anti-social behavior and and the
um open air consumption of alcohol and
behavior that results
why why the the the beach kiosk would be
adding to that given I suspect uh quite
a substantial pricing difference
interesting question basically there are
some youngsters who do drink on the
beach you know that I know that
they are basically not a big problem
because of the issue of the steps the
stairs up to Eastern Esplanade the fact
they've got to come enormous distances
most of them most of the year are simply
not there there simply is not a problem
there are problems further along because
if you look at some of the brightly lit
places you know kids tend to aim for
those so looking at the Viking Bay and
so on and I know there is disorder there
but you've got ready access to the
police two ambulances it's a much better
lip place
um if anybody has problems with people
on the beach doing that they at least
have got nearby
um residents and nearby
um shops and bars and so on where they
can go for help
your staff are going to be at such risk
I would not dare do what you're
suggesting because one I don't think
you're going to make much money because
I think you're right the kids are going
to bring their own drinks
can't see who's going to sit down there
because I love that stone Bay Area I've
got a house there I've lived there for
30 Years love it but it's very windy
it's very cold it's very isolated and
the older we get it's harder and harder
to go down those stairs never mind about
come up them again and if there were no
toilets why would you go down there when
you've got these other 149
Outlets Where You Are
um near toilets where you do have good
lighting where you're not going to be at
such risk
I just don't see that you'll get the
custom I'm trying to help you with your
business what I am worried about is that
it will attract drug dealers and it will
attract people
um that we don't want
you know the bottom of stone Bay
um doing the things I regularly expect
they will they did entire hamlets they
did when I was in deal I mean you know
these issues are not new for 40 years
now they've been the same you've got to
manage young people very carefully and
you've got to protect them and you've
got to protect people who are working in
the interests of the general public so
I've got no problem at all with what you
do now and I applaud it I think it's a
great family area we trotted along there
on Sunday we manage the steps this time
and the steps are very difficult but the
area was well organized the toilets were
nice we popped in we had to look at them
very clean we love what than it
counselor doing now to introduce
Licensing hours till 10 at night you're
asking for a major change down there and
it's not a good one and is putting a lot
of people at risk and that's why I so
strongly oppose this and why I've turned
up today to say that to you if you had
as much experience of young people as we
have between us including ball stools
and so on
um you'd know why we're so worried about
young people given half a chance they
don't behave quite as well as we do all
hope
sorry
uh
does the technical support team manager
have any questions for Mrs Moulton no
thank
you miss Moulton do you have any
questions for the support team manager
I don't honestly understand why the
police haven't objected to this they
have put conditions there but the
problem is I in 30 odd years have never
seen a police car anywhere near the
bottom of Eastern Esplanade
they don't come that way and I just
wonder personally being very cynical
whether or not they want the kids that
are taking drugs and drinking to move to
somewhere quieter less accessible to
them now I'm sure you can't answer that
but nevertheless it did occur to me that
that might be the reason they're not
objecting to this
and so obviously I appreciate you've
been there for 32 years and understand
the area better than anybody
um
we're also local been not that many but
five years so we just live up just
behind you and we're on them on the
beach every morning with the dogs and
we're down there with the kids in the
evening so we we know our after five
years the sort of pattern of what goes
on down there so it's not a there isn't
a general
problem on the beach as such there isn't
a you know there isn't a stream of kids
going down there and vandalizing and I
think for us
um for me being experienced and license
holder I would I would see that what
we're going to be offering is more of a
sort of a destination venue not looking
to draw people say from the tartar
frigate after they've had a few drinks
and walk a mile down to us I don't think
that would be and you are right that
would never happen and I think we'd be
commercially making the wrong decision
but what we are looking to do is become
a sort of a food-led place like you may
get in Cornwall where it's a a bit of
healthy food or some a nicely cooked
burger and and then we would see to
attract maybe small groups of as a
function so maybe a small celebration
where we could do a very intimate
Gathering 20 30 people and and I don't
think that we would
ever see us competing with the other
venues in broadstairs because I think
they've already got all that going on so
I think for us it's important to price
it right so that the clientele we are
only
focusing on the clientele that we
currently have
and when the people do leave the beach
at six because you're right the Sun
comes over and it does go into shade we
would only be looking for these hours
during the summer period so come the
winter we probably wouldn't be open
anyway so um we're looking to make the
most of the summer
and become a quite a a renowned spot for
people to be uh for people who've found
it to be proud of anyway and hopefully
get known across you know across the
sort of local areas being a place to
come with the kids relax and then if you
want to have your celebration there and
we can do that with food and we will
always be a sort of food LED operation
as opposed to being a sort of a a party
place and to keep the
the kids at Bay I think we
they are nice kids down there I've got
to say you know maybe that's back in
London there'll be a lot more vandalism
and they do go down for a good time
and they are aware of adults being
around and when we are there we notice
they don't come down that end they
disperse and maybe go where they can be
policed but if they're not being police
because they're in a hideout area like
Stone Bay then there definitely is the
chance of drugs and whatever else going
on because there are all those nooks and
crannies which then the following
morning you've got children around to be
a
to maybe stumble across whatever so
um we wouldn't be open all week anyway
it'd be weekends and we're hoping that
by us being if we are open a bit longer
can deter people from
hiding around the areas of the of the
local
area so yeah thank you and thanks for
your points
thank you very much and with the
exception of the subcommittee members
the Democratic Services officer and the
senior litigation lawyer please can I
ask those president to leave the chamber
so that the subcommittee can come to a
decision you'll be invited back to the
to the decision when announced
sorry can I just clarify one point sorry
just one point your application is from
Monday to Saturday you just mentioned
you wouldn't be open during the uh the
week and just the weekend just to
clarify is is that the case or
the weather permitting so
if we've got the four weeks option we
can then trade as we see we need to but
we're not going to be putting staff down
there seven days a week because it is a
destination
so more flexibility that we would be
looking for
okay Joseph just to confirm the the
application hours
um I thought it was it was it Monday to
Sunday six till ten from what I can see
eight or ten Monday to Sunday
I think do you have a copy of the
I do yeah
you can verify that
on page
17.
and all the way to Sunday 8 till 10.
okay and and that is
they can sell alcohol
all through that
timed yeah
okay well Embers what do you think well
well
basically I've been those licenses
they are suggesting tense or Tender to
sell alcohol okay okay
so at least wait till 11. exactly but
I'd run
um the nightclubs everyone pubs and bars
and leaves the best and he has said
exactly all the things that you would
want to hear from somebody who's doing
it plus he's talking about only doing a
certain amount of
stuff it's not like talking about 13
types of beer and 22 types of this it's
uh clearly going to be like Butler beer
yeah yeah and that's what it's been
saying and I think just yes that people
are going to come down and take drugs or
those are just a crazy person
yeah I I don't think that's all a
redhead I think they're just worried
about the I mean not it's not not about
that application that they're worried
about I think is it they don't know
about the whole vibe yeah I understand
their fears yeah but that's what they
are their fears what if this can happen
what what about that that is is what
could happen it's not it's not what has
happened plus as well if as he says if
they're down there with their staff
well um I would like to now invite Mr
katenge the senior litigation lawyer to
read a summary of the subcommittee's
determination
thank you upon considering whether to
Grant or to refuse a license for the
stone Bay kiosk broadstairs
and having considered the documentation
and representations made by the
licensing officer the applicant verbal
submissions made by Mr and Mrs Morton
and written submissions it is the
decision of the licensing board to Grant
a new license at the stone Bay kiosk
broadstairs under basis that the
conditions imposed in agenda Annex 5 be
complied with and under condition that
the kiosk is open from 10 to 10 on the
months of May June July August and under
other months up to 6 PM the board
recommends that the applicant should
consider installing a public sorry a
portable toilet in the proximity of the
premises this decision has been made in
line with the thanet district council's
licensing policy and objectives within
licensing act 2003. the applicants May
appeal this decision that the community
has made to the magistrates courts
within 21 days thanks thank you
[Music]